my talk at the table is about actress
rachel brosnahan who recently earned
another emmy nomination for her role in
the amazon prime video series the
marvelous mrs maisel
brosnahan plays miriam maisel or midge
as she's called
a 1950s housewife who decides to pursue
a career in stand-up comedy take a look
nice to know that people haven't
forgotten me
you haven't forgotten me my kids have
completely forgotten me they've gotten
very
jaded having a mother in show business i
showed up the other day my daughter
pointed to her diaper and said sweetie
would you get this
then she lit her cigarette refilled her
daiquiri bottle and fired her agent
now both her parents are in the abyss
oh yeah this is what happens when you
leave remember the first time
i love this show and the cool part is
that brosnahan brings that same energy
to her work
off screen she serves on the board of
directors for covenant house a nonprofit
that helps homeless youth and each year
she participates in the organization's
sleepout
where volunteers sleep outside to raise
money and awareness
for the more than four million homeless
kids in america
rachel brosnahan joins us now good
morning rachel thank you so much for
being here
good morning thank you for having me
this is actually your eighth year of
participating in the sleepout you
you started doing this when you were on
broadway at 23 and you say it
it changed your literally changed your
life
yeah absolutely i was profoundly moved
by my first sleepout and getting the
opportunity to see
inside the covenant house and meet some
of the young people who called it home
and meet some of the incredible staff
who have dedicated their lives to this
work
i was moved to make a commitment that
night to stay involved
and i'm so proud and honored to be here
eight years later
what what moved you specifically rachel
well i met a young man who called
covenant house home at the time
and he was 23 years old and so was i
and i was really struck by how with just
a few small shifts in circumstance
we could be sitting on opposite sides of
the table
we were peers and that is supremely
unfair
that our situations were so different
yeah the sleepout this year obviously
has to be different
uh what's what are you going to do this
year
so this year uh it'll be a virtual event
obviously given what's going on
in the country and in the world but
we'll be sleeping out wherever we can
find a space whether that be
a backyard or a front yard or a living
room
i think that's where we're going to
sleep out tonight but the programming
will remain largely the same
just just in our little computer boxes
so the and so the spirit will be the
same as well
absolutely yeah you as i mentioned uh
congrats on another emmy nomination
uh how did you celebrate by the way yeah
uh well it's a little different right
now
um so i have i have a little pod that
i've been with
since march and i don't know we wanted
to do something
exciting and and somehow we came up with
making match s'mores otherwise known as
apartment s'mores
um you light a match and you
hold the marshmallow over it and it did
it felt special and celebratory
so are you planning to get dressed up
for the emmys themselves even though
you'll be at home
i'm definitely going to do something
special yeah i mean
i get to bring my dogs to the emmys how
often is that gonna happen
it's gonna be a fun night i was struck
by something that i read you'd said
before which is that you'd actually
lost parts because you weren't funny
enough
that must have made auditioning for mrs
maisel who's a stand-up comedian
pretty intimidating yeah
definitely it's still intimidating we're
three
four years in and it doesn't get any
less intimidating
but i think it just goes to show that we
shouldn't put ourselves in those boxes
you know for a long time i had
turned down auditions because i'd been
told for so long that
that i wasn't very funny it's also a
testament to brilliant writing
yeah well you could say brilliant
writing but uh rachel gail here you
could also say it's brilliant acting
because i love the show i love you in
the show and i want to pick up on what
anthony was saying because that's what i
was
thinking i said she must have done
stand-up comedy before
so to learn that you had never done it
because your timing and delivery is so
good so i wonder how did you do that and
it's fun to watch the evolution of your
character
because first she was a little tentative
and now she is all in
yeah yeah well i think it's just that
you know at first
she wasn't she wasn't a tried and true
tested stand-up she was just a funny
woman having a mental breakdown
in a very public forum and uh and as
she's gone on she's had to learn and and
refine her craft and and that's been
really fun for me
in bringing her to life but how did you
learn to do it rachel did you go to
different comedy clubs
is that how you became so good at it i
know it's acting i get that
but how did you prepare for it
not as a stand-up but i did drag poor
michael zegan who plays joel
uh all over the city to various comedy
clubs
mostly just to see how people were when
they started
how they responded to unexpected success
or unexpected failure in the moment
and um and i still try to go whenever i
can
it wasn't a world i was very familiar
with but i watch a lot of stand-up now
yeah i bet you do we'll be waiting for
season four whenever you guys come back
we're sarah you've been disruptive but
we can't wait till you get back to work
rachel brosnan thank you so much
the covenant house stage and screen
virtual sleep out is tonight
and the marvelous mrs maisel is
streaming now on amazon prime
video if you haven't started watching
now's a good time since we're all at
home and at collective time out